i want to start with a sort of big
picture
right so we're going to kind of
introduce energy storage
and then we'll talk about sort of why
you know electrical storage is
is kind of a thing and important and
then we'll kind of go into batteries and
then
talk about the chemistry of batteries
and throw in a couple of why this
matters
so if you think about this on a
planetary scale
um actually the planet is kind of a
storage device
it's an energy storage device for that
thing over there
right and so so like if you think about
like all the energy flows that go on on
planet earth
um well then you know you've got you
know there's a picture i like it so
it kind of shows you the the different
energy flows are you got the sun so
you've got like solar radiation you've
got tides there's a moon
you know you've got wind you've got all
these kinds of energy happening on the
planet all the way down to life
right happening uh rock formation
right and then and then sometimes you
know those things your rocks can
you know you form ally alloys
over millions and millions of years and
the thing is if you think about this um
where you draw the line is somewhat
arbitrary
right in a sense right it sort of
depends on our use i mean
if you think about it fossil fuels are
actually a renewable
source of energy right on geological
scales
um the the the problem is it so it's
like you know 10
20 30 million year old sunlight right
and it'll happen again
uh but the the question is how do we
store energy on time skills that matter
to
us and so you can draw this line and
then think about what that means and
and typically you know so most most sort
of energy storage needs are going to be
around a year or less
all right okay now um okay
so now why electricity why electricity
right so so the thing is um uh
electricity is more and more important
in our lives and if you look at just
sort of like the major sectors right so
you have like the power generation
you have transportation you have
industry of buildings and this is a plot
of these sectors
and the co2 emissions you can plot all
sorts of things about these sectors this
is co2
um versus time these are kind of the
major contributors but see the thing is
electricity because of of things that
are happening as well
the opportunity either the use of
electricity now
right like power to your home or the
opportunity to use it
a lot more later like transportation
that means that electricity has sort of
about a 70 percent role
about a 70 opportunity of all of this
right that's how much electricity
matters here
well but the thing is that electricity
as you know in an electric car
it's not going to be useful if you have
to have it plugged in all the time right
and so
most of this 70 percent
most of this 70 i want to emphasize is
not
currently it's the potential for for the
electrification of our world that is
happening that's how much
electricity will play a role um and but
most of it is useless unless you can
store it right
um so storage of electricity is clearly
really really
important um and so we get to sort of
how do you think about storage
technologies and again i just want to
kind of gently introduce us to energy
storage and then we'll go into batteries
um now um the so the
the kind of plot that i'm showing you
here we're already talking about ashby
plots right
but this is actually a different kind
it's a special kind because it has to do
with
uh energy uh storage and
and there's a guy who in the 1960s
david rigoni um
he first and and it's actually
fascinating he wrote a paper in 1968
a review of batteries for electric
vehicles
in 1968 right and he either how do i how
do i put you know there's all these
possibilities we want to electrify our
transportation fleet
but which batteries make the most sense
and so he he decided to plot them
on these two axes energy stored versus
the power
and that's a very common way these are
called regoni plots now
so it's the energy
versus power and this is how you'll see
a lot
of discussions if you look online and
you're interested in energy storage as a
field
um you'll see a lot of plots like this
right where
you got uh oh but okay so energy is like
watt hours right for example this would
be like watts
times hours and this would be like the
watts
right so so one of the nice things about
plots like this
and and you know mostly it's almost
always on a log scale so you can get
stretch out and see all the different
technologies on one plot
right and one of the nice things about
apology is that this is energy
this is energy and this is energy per
time
right and so right that's
that's energy per time times time okay
so we can we can have lots of fun with
that um
but so what that means if you think
about a little bit is that
you know if you plot energy storage
technologies on plots like this then
these diagonal lines are how much these
ag lines are one number
of time right it's like if you had a
given density and a given
and you're using it at a given rate a
given power
right then that's how long it would last
so these plots are really convenient
they're really convenient ways to
compare energy technologies
okay so those that would be like i've
got energy storage
uh technology and it's you know it's got
this much density this much power well
then it's gonna last if i use it at that
power for 41 days
right and so forth now you see there's
lots of lots of stuff on here
why don't i just want high and high
that sounds like a good thing right so
shouldn't we be putting
pumping water up hills like all over the
place
well obviously if you think about like
you know you don't do that in your phone
you don't even do that in your backyard
you don't even do that in a town
why because pumped hydro is
extraordinarily limited
you have to do it at very large scales
it's very low energy density
right it's geographically highly
constrained um it is one of the
oldest ways we have of storing energy
right
i'll just think of the water wheel but
um but it's it's very constrained so we
can't use this in most applications
pumped hydro but okay so and then oh
this is compressed air
compressed air caes that sounds good
that's got a whole lot of limitations as
well
we've got uh this just to give you the
abbreviations super conducting
magnetic coils superconductors right
just keep it going
and then you draw the and it just keeps
going forever it's a great battery right
except for all the problems that it has
and how much it costs
and how much it costs but it's a really
cool concept and it's here right all of
these things exist
all these things exist they all exist
and they're all
very interesting and important energy
storage
devices they're interesting important
electrical energy storage devices right
so so
that's that's the main point so like
here you know super caps you build up a
lot of charge
right in a solid here you've got
flywheels well i'm just rotating
something heavy really really fast
i get worried about that i want to be in
that in that building
but they do build flywheel energy
storage devices
you know you you slow it down and then
you generate electricity from that
right and so so these kinds of plots are
really really really helpful for
comparing one energy technology with
another
now um the thing is as i said there's a
there's a whole list of these and it
goes on and on but they've also all got
oh that's really hard to see
they've all got a lot of limitations
right and so you have
you know capacitors have a low density
uh
you can convert energy into some fuel
and store it and then combust it that's
got low round trip efficiency
um this is what we're going to talk
about today electrochemical there are
challenges there too
um kinetic pump hydra there's so many
different ways of storing energy
yep um the thing is there is an
advantage
that i want to mention about using
electrochemistry
there is an advantage about using
electrochemistry and
and um what what is electro i just said
the word electrochemistry
i should tell you what that is right and
it's the relationship
of the relationship between
because in tight between electricity
electricity
and
chemical reactions
oh i love saving time ruxins
that's equal to electrochemistry electro
this is in it now electrochemistry
okay and so what you'll see is like
things like electrochemical
energy storage right and they're there
this
this isn't just this isn't just one type
of thing it's not just
one type of battery it's not even just
batteries
it's this broader definition um
but but we're going to talk about
batteries today now there's
there's a little there so there's
something else that's really useful
so i mentioned you know we're getting to
that point where we're electrifying
everything
there's we need electricity almost
everywhere even in your combustion car
you need electricity a lot more than you
used to than 20 years ago
right and and so as we electrify our
world
you said he started thinking and then i
said i gotta store that energy
he starts to think about what carnot did
now i'm paraphrasing here but this is uh
basically what he said
if you think about how it applies to
this conversion
and which is that the second law of
thermodynamics
makes you pay a penalty of energy
if you convert it into heat and then
back into electricity
well even if you just have heat in the
first place and now you want to generate
electricity from that
you're limited so it's we talked about
this before right like the
the energy density of gasoline it's so
it's so high and it's such an
amazing energy storage material because
you can transport it safely
right yeah but the thing is then you put
it i just made the i just gave you the
example of the car you put in your car
does anybody know how efficient how much
of that energy your car actually uses to
move
percentage-wise
take a guess yeah it's 20 maybe 10 to
20.
depends on the car my car probably five
that's an old car but you know it's so
most of that gasoline's energy is going
into waste
why carnot now this is not a
thermodynamics class but this comes in
to this so i wanted to mention
carnot and the fact that there is
another way to do it
so you could do chemical reaction to
heat that's how we power most of our
world today
right a power plant gets up to higher
temperature
so the penalty is less but still most
power plants you lose about 50 percent
right most power plants at best are
around 50
efficient in terms of converting the
thermal energy into electrical energy
yeah but i could convert i can use a
different way and that's
electrochemistry
and it's one of the reasons why
electrochemical energy storage is so
appealing
is because you don't really pay a
penalty right
you don't really pay a penalty i can go
back and forth without
the second law hurting me
so um i want to mention something about
about carnot about the second law and
again this is not a class
on thermal but but the second law
involves entropy so i had to say
something especially because um it's in
april
right and that that's your textbook that
you're all diligently reading every day
and um and there it is by the way april
has a beautiful chapter on batteries
chapter 19
i'm sure you know it's really well
written
like this is what he says about entropy
though and for now we can state that
entropy
is a thermodynamic property of all
substances that is proportional to their
degree of disorder
april such a good book
but look let me ask you guys a question
what is it
there's this real so so
people think about entropy as disorder
and they think about entropy as sort of
you know more disorder let me ask you
which
which one of these has a higher entropy
the one on the left
or the one on the right so i these are
these are
this is about right so how many of you
think the one on the left
has a higher entropy how many of you
think it's the one on the right
i kind of so so the thing is
it's the one on the left yeah
right i love that you guys are blown
away
why because entropy is not about
smoothness and it's not about disorder
that is wrong
entropy is about accessibility to states
it's about how many states you have to
be in
now that can appear to be like disorder
right
um but a messier room does not have
higher entropy
and in this case it's just simply the
rules of the algorithm
i have rules here about the dots being
able to touch each other
they're randomly selected but with the
constraint that they cannot touch each
other
that means that those dots had fewer
possibilities they had fewer states
that they could be in this system has
much higher entropy
it's about the number of states i just
want to make that you know this again
is not the topic of this class but i got
to make my my case about entropy when i
can
and i brought up carnal so there you go
all right entropy is not just disorder
now okay so we're back to batteries now
so electrochemistry
you know there's a lot of reasons why
electrochemical storage
is is one you know here's the here's the
chart again right it's this one here
you see that electrochemical batteries
all right that we're going to talk about
there's a lot of reasons why this is so
appealing
no penalty on the second law is one of
them um
you can have transport easily right and
drive electric cars you can see that
no pollution at the point of use
pollution is can be
focused at the point of production it
could also be
you know batteries can be charged by
renewable technologies like
solar and wind and they're very highly
efficient electric cars for example
have a very high efficiency depending on
the car but you know
upwards of 90 in terms of converting
that electrical energy back and forth
the metrics that matter i wrote a couple
of them here right
watts watt hours these are the things
that matter in batteries
but but so many other things matter and
this is why this is a complicated
problem and it's also why
batteries are not not in any way a one
size fits all
i mean you know that from like double
a's and and and triple a's and
and nine volt but it's so much more than
that because it's about the application
uh uh change not going from your
computer to your phone
you know uh but but going from like uh
your car
right uh to your phone to a house to a
grid
and so the needs are all going to be
different
and and then which ones of these things
you care about is going to depend on
what chemistry
you think about it all comes down to the
chemistry as we're going to see
it's all about the chemistry and and
just to put a few numbers down
cell phone is a few watts of power light
bulb is 10 to
10 to 100 aaa battery has 1.5 watt hours
of storage right so that's how much
energy is
inside of a aaa battery uh needed to
drive a car 200 miles 100 kilowatt hours
it's just fun to think about these
things right powering your house 40
kilowatts max depending on how many ac
units you're running uh the world is uh
is this many watts as of a few
years ago so if you had um i think it's
something like 20 000 billion
aaa batteries you could run the world
for an hour ish
something like that these numbers are
just fun to play with so i want to put a
few examples down
so where did it all begin it all began
with an argument
it all began with this beautiful
argument
that i have to tell you because it's
it's really a cool piece of history
and and it and it took place in italy
and it was galvani
who was a physiologist and he really
loved
the the topic of why animals move right
now so why what is motion how is it that
that that animals are moving uh you know
how am i moving my muscles how is how is
anything well there had been theories
about this going all the way back you
remember like socrates and you know
plato you know the the elements right
and ether
there were similar theories for motion
of the human body
in fact the word pneuma was used
uh to describe the essence that goes
through
all living things that allows them to
move well so
galdoni didn't like that he wanted
something more concrete and so he was
really
trying to make a connection especially
between things that move and electricity
and electricity now there was it was
difficult there wasn't like a constant
source so you had electric generators in
your in your lab at the time
um but galdoni wanted to go big so he
hooked up his lightning rod to a frog
the frog was not alive well
they're probably not alive but seriously
but because then you'll see why
at least i don't think so i really hope
not
now i'm thinking about i'm getting a
little bumped honestly but i don't think
they were alive
it doesn't look alive so he hooked him
up to lightning rods
and he watched and he waited as the
storms come in and he's like
the the lightning rod hits and and he
hooked him up to some metals and
the frog went crazy it's like aha
motion electricity he'd been jolting
them in his lab with his own electric
generator and see
but he wanted to go big and he also they
didn't know
they didn't know at the time what
electricity was
right so so they didn't know if the
electricity that he generated in his own
thing
was the same as the electricity came
from the sky and he saw that you get the
same result
the frog still moved
so galvani said that the motion
of of a frog leg in all motion of all
living creatures
generates electricity that's what he
said
he deduced that the motion itself is
uh is something that generates
electricity this is a really cool little
article about this
debate because in in galvani's case
if you have two metal wires hooked up to
a frog leg we say if you close the loop
then what he said is that
the charge that was already in there
moves around the loop
and back and makes the leg move you see
volta got really interested in this and
he said you know
let me study this he he's he was a
physicist at the time
um and and and he he said you know this
looks fascinating let me study it
but he said you know um why do you keep
using two different
why metals why can't you know if so i
think this is about the metals
not the frog and they had a big huge
argument right so this is volta's
picture
is that it's when you connect two
different metals that you get a charge
flowing
through the flock to the frog volta
i think as many of you know went on to
win that argument
uh and and we have the volt named in
after him and he also created the first
uh stable battery the
voltaic pile um galvani on the other
hand really opened the doors
to to the idea that we have electricity
in our bodies which is pretty cool
he also is a reason why the story of
frankenstein was written
because you know it it's actually true
because
they they went around and and took
all sorts of things and and electrocuted
them and
showed that they moved and and often
they weren't alive and so
mary shelley i think saw that he went
around like the countryside
shocking people and i actually meant
that as like
not literally but just shocking them by
what he's
doing um and i don't think they ever
used humans but still
people's imaginations you know and so
forth and it was quite a thing
okay very interesting story now why does
this matter i've got two why this
matters today my first one is on this
on a personal scale smaller scale and
then my
my next one is on a grid scale so so
this is called a little sun
there's over a billion people who can't
read at night
uh because there's no access to
electricity um
and and of course a lot of the studying
that you could do would be at night
right so this is a really cool program
why does this work this is a solar cell
but this wouldn't work unless you could
store the electricity
right so i wanted to make you guys aware
of little sun i'll pass it around you
just press this
and you can read at night right this is
already
making a big difference in millions of
people's lives
that doesn't happen unless you've got
electrochemical energy storage
right and there's some some stats
up here uh 25 billion liters of kerosene
are used
uh to meet the basic lighting needs in a
lot of these places uh that releases
tremendous amounts
of um of toxic fumes um and
and you can you can you know you can
make a huge difference but you can't
you know serve the same as cooking right
so so so wood fire cooking is a huge
problem
uh the but so the challenge is but you
you don't cook
if you have a solar cooker that's great
except that most people don't cook
during the day they cook at night or in
the morning
right um and so how do you so you've got
to store
energy to make these things actually
useful
right and and i really like this program
so i wanted to make that
one of my why this matters and we'll go
big on the next one
but let's get to the chemistry so what
happens
in a battery the best way to understand
this is with a classic example of two
different metals it's volta's two
different metals it could be any
voltage did lots of metals that's we did
and he showed that the fro yeah so but
the frog moved
with most of them so it was the metals
so let's take these two classic
uh metals uh and show what happens
you've got
copper and you've got um zinc now in
this case i'm just gonna have a zinc
this is the zinc piece of metal
this is a piece of zinc and i put it in
a solution
of copper ions right and so so in this
case
uh what do we have let's write this down
in this case
i've got uh zinc
uh let's see zinc solid
that is well let me before i write this
down
let's write down what the what's in the
solution the solution is copper sulfate
and this goes to everything that we've
been talking about
so i've got a solution a beaker
that is copper ions in it
how much i don't know look up the ksp
right now we know how to do that so4
uh two minus in solution so you put
you put some of this copper sulfate
powder in that beaker turns blue and it
gives you these ions
that are dissolved in solution and then
you put a piece of zinc in there
and then you put a piece of zinc in
there now so so what happens
what happens is is there's a transfer
of electrons right now now we we've
talked a lot about electrons
we talked about transverse electron i
mean just think about it right we went
from
h all right like this look at that right
the bonding and then we did this
okay here we go it's a little bit less
sharing
but still right and then we did you know
we did this
right we did this where it's like okay
there's almost nothing there
it all went there this is where my
electrons are right
well then we put this in water and we
got this
okay right and we got them sort of
separated and and they
and this one just just broke off with
its electron
leaving a positive charge behind so
we've done all this we know this
right yeah but so what's happening here
is special because what's happening here
is a trading of electrons
you see in all the bonding that we've
done we've talked about how electrons
share
in bonds and then these things break
apart
but now i'm going to do reactions that
trade them
that's electrochemistry that's
electrochemistry and what happens when i
put that zinc strip
into that solution is this the zinc
goes into solution it's two plus and
two electrons and the copper
in the solution plates onto the zinc
plus those two electrons goes to
copper like that and if you if you look
at the full reaction
the full reaction would be then zinc
solid
plus copper two plus
in solution goes to zinc
two plus in solution
plus copper solid that's the trading now
i like writing it like this
because you really see explicitly the
gain the gaining and losing of electrons
oh those have words
associated with them gaining and losing
of electrons yeah but this is the this
is the reaction that we're kind of used
to
right so this is just the same thing
it's what happens
right it's what happens it's a trade of
electrons
now it turns out that when when
something
loses electrons like that we call that
oxidation
and when something gains electrons we
call this reduction
reduction and so when
when two different materials in this
case these two metals trade electrons
and one of them is oxidized and one of
them is reduced that's also got a name
it's called a redox couple
those are a redox couple redox
redux right okay
so these are a redox couple
is what they're called when you trade
electrons like this now
okay so what's happening well what's
happening is at the cir
i mean you know at the surface of the
zinc
i see these copper ions in solution and
it's like well
if i you know if i gave you two
electrons
then you'd be you'd be able to become a
copper solid
right and so so if i get if i give you
two electrons you're a copper solid
and and if i but now if i lose two
electrons as a zinc atom
i'm a zinc 2 plus that's this
that's just this right i said why does
that happen
well we'll get to that right but that's
what's happening so a zinc atom at this
surface
right a zinc atom at the surface sees a
copper two plus
and it says here have two electrons oh
and then it's like wait a second
i gave two electrons away i gotta go
into solution
and that's exactly what you see over
here right the copper is plating
the zinc and the and the zinc is coming
off of the
off of the strip they're doing this all
right
why is that happening you put that strip
in there and the thing just heats up
this is exothermic that means that this
reaction will go
this is spontaneous this is spontaneous
where can i write that nowhere
spontaneous spontaneous
it didn't have to be as we'll see but
this one is
that but all that's happening is you're
so you're you're giving
you're you're going down in energy
you're giving energy away
and you're heating up the environment
now the question is how can i not let
that happen
how can i stop the heating from happen
and instead take advantage of this
electron trading
to do work that's what a battery is
that's what a battery is
it's it's taking advantage of this and
really what it comes down to is just
a different construction of the device
it's this
the fundamentals of a battery is it's
this kind of thing
but now instead of allowing this plating
to happen
i'm going to separate that and i'm going
to construct it in such a way
that those electrons get traded through
some wire that i can do work with okay
so for example
um where is it
okay maybe not for example maybe for
example
maybe i need to turn this on and off
um there we go this is the picture that
april gives for the battery
so what you saw wasn't a battery because
i wasn't stopping the electron flow and
doing anything but if you construct it
like this this is called a galvanic cell
right if you construct it like this now
i can do work with that electron trade
right i can do work with the electron
trade that's the difference so let's go
through this
so on the left so what did i do well i
got my zinc strip
but now i've got a copper strip
just trying to see okay i've got a
copper strip over here i've got a zinc
strip over here
right but i'm putting the zinc not into
the copper directly
where i just short it and the whole
thing just heats up instead i'm putting
the zinc into a solution of zinc ions
look at that zinc has zinc ions
in solution right a copper
copper is in a solution of copper ions
so these are now the two beakers
on the left i've got you know zinc
nitrate in this case it's a nitrate not
a sulfate
it doesn't matter the whole point of the
solution
is that i get these ions in a beaker i
get these ions in a beaker
so um you know so so you got the copper
ions
in a beaker on the right with the copper
solid and you got the zinc ions there
let's look at what's happening
at blow up of those those different
sides right so at the anode
it's called the anode because it's where
the charge comes from
it's called the anode what's happening
well what's happening is
what i just showed you the zinc
is leaving the solid the zinc is leaving
the solid
and it's becoming two plus it's becoming
two plus
right but you know so if it but the
the thing is that it now you got to be
careful here so the zinc is becoming two
plus
um it's where what about those two
electrons
where do they go a zinc atom leaves its
metal strip and goes into that beaker of
zinc ions
right but but now you've got two charges
two electrons on the strip
because it left a zinc two plus nothing
more will happen
nothing more will happen unless those
two electrons go away
that's the whole point what's so cool
about batteries
is that it's all about neutrality you
can't have you know
you think about batteries as current
flowing batteries is all about
neutrality
it's all about keeping these things
neutral because if i just build this
charge up here
i can't have another zinc atom go in so
the charge has to go somewhere but
that's what that wire is for
that's what this wire is for right this
wire allows the charge to go over to the
other place the cathode
where the copper is sitting there saying
you know what
you know if i had two electrons if i had
two electrons on the copper strip
then i could use those as a way to lure
in a copper two plus ion
right i could use those as a way to
learn and if i did that then i'm doing
what this did
right here right it's the same
thing that we just did with the plating
except now those electrons
are going through this wire up here the
zinc is trading electrons with the
copper
that's keeping this neutral so now the
the electrons go away
and now another zinc can go into
solution then the copper grabs them
plates a piece of copper and then more
electrons can come
right it's the same thing it's the same
thing
this is what this is what it looks like
if you take those electrodes out of the
solutions
after running this for you know
five ten minutes look at what happened
the copper plated
you got copper ions from solution
plating that and zinc ions from solution
leaving that leaving that and so those
are the reactions that are happening
one's happening on the zinc side one's
happening on the other side but there's
something else
there's something else because you
wouldn't have there's this one other
piece of it that you got to understand
to understand how a battery works and
it's this thing here
right so up here the elect this is my
conduit for electrons to go
each time it goes i can plate i can lose
more goes right but see but but notice
if i
lose two plus if i lose two so i've got
these two plus
what how did i it's not charged the
solution is
you know this look at this copper
sulfate in that case is copper nitrate
copper sulfate goes into solution it's
not a charged solution these things
are balanced right two plus two minus
so now i'm taking only a two plus out of
solution no way
it's the same thing you gotta make it
neutral again
right it won't work otherwise you can't
start building up charge in the solution
so that's what this thing is about
that's what this is
this is called the salt bridge and that
completes the circuit
see this lets the electrons flow this
gives ions it doesn't matter what it is
right that's the electrolyte it's just a
source of ions here it's nacl
it's nacl so now for every copper two
plus
that plates onto the copper electrode
two n a plus atoms go into this beaker
from the bridge because here i've got
dissolved salt dissolve salt
sodium chloride is in water so i got all
these sodium ions i got all these
chlorine ions all right and and when
when uh when a
a charge imbalance happens because
something plates here i can draw
sodium atoms out of the salt bridge and
i can draw chlorine atoms out of that
side right
that completes your circuit that's an
ion neutralizer the salt bridge and this
is
allowing the electrons to keep
everything neutral and that's how you
get the current
right it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
stuff
now the thing is um you can do this
yourself that's what i brought these
for is that you know you can
so you know somebody says the potato
battery i like the human battery
um these are just volt meters
and these are um uh uh
set to the right thing yep and what
you'll find you know you can you can uh
you can see what happens right like if
you when you touch
when you touch the two electrodes yeah
and you sometimes you got to squeeze oh
look at that
current you you have electro
you are providing you're the salt bridge
you are the bridge so what that means is
you are actually plating
and taking metals off of these two
electrodes right now your hands are
doing that
and you're trading electrons you're a
conduit
for that to happen right you're the salt
bridge it's pretty cool and you can play
with these
they're really this is like i you know
you have volt meters
you have lots of items on the table
tomorrow maybe at a dinner
and i'm just suggesting that you play
around with this idea because
look this is what volta did
this is literally what the name of that
device
the guy that that's named after this is
what he did
he hooked up two different metals i just
put some paper clips in there it works
it can be almost not almost but lots of
different metals will work
why we'll get to that in a sec here i've
got another paper clip and a copper wire
right two different metals the power the
power isn't coming
from you as galvani thought
no the power is coming from the
difference
in potentials of those metals wanting or
not wanting electrons
everybody wants electrons let's be
honest but who wants them more
it all comes back to the same stuff we
talked about it's just that now we're
talking about the metals and whether
they're
they're more interested than the other
metal in having those two electrons
that's what a potential is that's what a
potential is
oh so you know so the ques so those are
that's a now so okay here we go
uh there's the vol so what determines it
right
what determines the potential
what determines the potential well it's
it's what i just said you know
intuitively
it's it's the difference in these things
wanting let's say
well okay i got copper and zinc how you
know
how do i know well you know
if you look at zinc
let's see where do i have it here we go
zinc i want to make sure i get this
right
so zinc is
argon and 3d
10 and 4s2
all right okay copper oh we got numbers
30 and 29 copper
is uh is the same thing in terms of its
core argon core 3d 10
4s1
which one of those wants to give up two
electrons
or take two electrons more than the
other
that's what determines the potential
that's what the and you know when you
look at this
you might say and this is from april so
he actually is missing the f's
because this is just taken right from
the textbook but anyway
um so so you know you say that's the
potential
look at this this is like an energy
diagram but these aren't electronic
states these are just
potentials but the potential is related
to
which one wants the two electrons more
it's two plus the oxidation state is two
plus
so you know you look at this you say
well i don't know which one might give
up electrons more i mean this
you know it turns out it's the zinc
and you might say well but wait a second
this has this is if i just take an
electron out of here won't it be
harder than one out of here because this
only has 4s1
right the answer is yes but i'm taking
two
i'm not taking one i'm talking about the
oxidation state of two plus
that's going to be harder here it's
harder to take a 4s1 and a 3d
from that beautifully filled 3d shell
than it is to take these two s electrons
that's why that's higher
that's why that's higher right so
you know so you could what you can see
is that the potential difference
the potential difference is all about
chemistry
right the v the delta v
is all about
the chemistry the you know it's the
chemist
it's all about all the things that we've
learned it's it's
more than that because of these
solutions so it's more complicated than
that but at the core
of all of this is the all the topics
that we've learned
right how strongly are electrons bound
to an atom to into a metal
right um and and so you know so
you know you said well if i took if i
took cobalt
what would happen right if i took cobalt
instead of copper
the voltage here would be half and and
you can you can
you can sort of look at the periodic
table and think about why that is cobalt
has a 4s2 but it's got less d
electrons and so which of you know so is
it going to be easier or harder to pull
them out well it's going to be easier
than copper
but harder than zinc so it goes in the
middle
right and so the potential difference is
less for cobalt and zinc
but you still get a potential right and
so that's what volta did
and he did all sorts of different metals
and you know it's why you can understand
why copper
and why zinc and copper does this but
copper and zinc doesn't
that's copper in a zinc solution that's
zinc in a copper solution
nothing happens the reason
is the potential it's just this
it's it's just literally the the
potential difference that we just drew
this is this is going to be easier to
take
so i'm not going to go the other way
right i'm not going to go the other way
so nothing happens when you do that
and then finally the last kind of piece
of this is that we need a reference
because you can only get the changes and
potentials it's like enthalpy you can
only get the changes not the absolutes
so you got to have a standardization
and the standardization in the world of
batteries is hydrogen
so so there's so what you do when you
think about battery potentials
is you write down all of these reduction
reduction is gaining electrons right you
write down all
it doesn't matter you can write
reduction you can write oxidation
they're just to flip
flip the sign right it's just a flip
sign of the
of the potential but but you write these
down with respect to a common electrode
and and it's the standard it's called
the standard hydrogen electrode
so sometimes you'll see it as the she in
the battery world
and what it is is is just a very nice
platinum electrode that doesn't change
so it doesn't plate or lose
atoms and and it's a reaction that on
that electrode happens with hydrogen
hydrogen gas
and so what you do is you hook this up
on one side
you hook that up on one side and then
you put all the metals against that
and you measure their potential
what's so powerful about the she is that
now
i've got all these with respect to the
same reference right so now when i look
at my zinc copper battery
well it's just the difference between
those that's the potential of the
battery
so hydrogen electrodes gives you that
that ability
to standardize it and create huge tables
and if you look up potentials of
reduction
you're gonna they're all related to
hydrogen you get thousands of them
how much does somebody want to lose how
many electrons
that's going to be in these tables and
it's it's by a setup that
is very similar to the one i showed you
that is related to
hydrogen okay you can go the other way
so if i had if i had zinc
i just showed you zinc right copper and
zinc doesn't happen because it's the
wrong sign
but then what if i put copper instead of
in zinc i put copper and silver so
there's copper and zinc
copper and silver it works right because
now silver is down here
how did i know that because i hooked it
up to hydrogen and i compared it
to copper right and so that's how that's
how you do battery chemistry is you look
things up
you look up these potentials in uh
tables
and you think about which voltage you
need and that gets us to
um this nobel prize i
say well why are lithium why did the
lithium why did the nobel prize go to
the
the the uh not discovery but you know
the
the the the development of lithium-ion
as a storage technology and the reason
is
this it's all but did you you saw it was
the highest one on the list too
look at that so now i don't know what
the potential of a lithium-something
battery is going to be but i'm starting
out with a pretty
uh a pretty negative voltage respect to
hydrogen that
makes you think you might get high
voltages and you do
yeah but you have another thing that's
really cool about lithium is how light
it is
and those things combine make it a
beautiful battery
technology and that's why the nobel
prize was given because if you look at
it on a plot like this
it's all the way up here if you look at
energy density versus
volume and a lithium battery works much
the same way in the sense that you have
the separator here that's the
electrolyte
but now it's rechargeable and i didn't
you know
i don't have time to go into
rechargeable batteries versus what are
called primary batteries which is the
one i showed you
um but all the chemistry is the same
you're shuttling ions back and forth
you've got that external circuit um and
what i wanted to and there's a whole
bunch of chemistry so what has exploded
in the last
well that's a bad word for batteries um
because that is a danger with lithium
batteries
but but what has really made the field
take off
is you know the word we're in the class
it's chemistry because the flexibility
of of where you can put that other
electrode
and what properties it has gives you
enormous room that's why lithium-ion
batteries can go in everything now
all the way up to the grid and that's
how that was my my last why this matters
in the last
two and a half minutes this is the grid
now so we went from
from small to very big right the growth
in solar
and wind has been incredible over the
last uh 10
20 years um the the problem as i think
i've shown you is the variability
and so this is like you know if you zoom
in here that's the load the black line
and this is like what these two
resources give you
and you can see that it doesn't match if
you zoom in on a day
then you really can see it right there's
the load and there's what you'd get from
solar and wind
and so here's the question he said well
okay how do you how do you fix this
you got to store it there's no way
to use renewables at large scales unless
you store it in fact
we're really at essentially the tipping
point because if i look at the countries
in the world and what there's pv
penetration is and this is a couple
years old but it's still
pretty much the same germany greece
italy at the top
uh uh sa frowny face here for the us of
a
um but but you know germany is at 7.1
percent as a few years ago
that's a huge penetration of pv well
here's the problem
if you if you look at this is germany
now
huge penetration these are these six
years right seven years of adding
pv this is how much they had they're now
at seven percent 2016
this is how much the price of
electricity was in germany when they
added
so notice that here's the sunlight
electricity during the day
they can sell it for a lot of money but
as they add more and more of this
renewable to the grid
its price goes down when it's available
in fact
it's now not economical for them to add
more pv
unless they can add it with storage
because actually the price has gone down
so much and it's gone
up here when they're not generating any
pb electricity
so you can come up with and they did in
this paper um this sort of value factor
which when it goes below one means
there's no
economic outcome that's positive here
right you can't make money anymore
and that look at where that happens it's
right around where they are it's at five
percent
you can't solve renewables at the scale
of the grid without storage and no
option exists today it might be
batteries it might be batteries but
there's nothing that actually does it
today
at the scales that we need so that's a
real challenge for
chemistry and i hope you guys um have a
great thanksgiving and maybe hook up
some
different medals um and i'll see you all
next week
you